hello there I'm John Oliver host of last
week tonight we are off until February
but with the holiday season now underway
we thought we'd share some important
advice regarding exchanging gifts with
friends and family because during the
holidays you are going to receive at
least one profoundly underwhelming gift
that's just a fact at some point this
month you will unwrap a present that
induces the sort of jaw-dropping
disappointment that one normally
associate with the term lettuce wrap but
for instance presents you might receive
a scented candle which is just a candle
that's extra desperate for attention or
maybe you'll get an edible arrangement
which says I don't know you very well
but if you're anything like me you have
to eat or else you'll die or maybe
you'll get a stuffed animal which is
essentially just a creepy ornament you
have to reposition before you can
comfortably have sex and that is why
that is why I am here with a handy
holiday guide to the art of rediff ting
it's the easiest way to pawn off
something that you can't stand aside
from sending your child to summer camp
first of all first of all never read
it's never a gift to someone who knows
the original gift er it's incredibly
uncomfortable to get busted ditching
something that was clearly meant for you
whether it's an ugly sweater or worst
case scenario and engagement ring worse
worst case scenario you're going to want
to create some distance so the ideal
place for a regifter is clearly an
office Secret Santa because re gifting
dare is like peeing in the ocean
sure sure it's not right but it's an
ultimately harmless solution to an
urgent problem secondly you're going to
want to personalize it write a note to
throw the recipient off the scent that
this gift was not originally meant for
them something intimate yet vague like
saw this and couldn't resist or this is
so you although I will say do be warned
that could backfire if the original gift
could be potentially insulting like a
self-help book or maybe a box of wine
really really you saw this box of wine
and you thought of me I'm three months
sober and you're an Nana you're
an
next you're gonna want to disguise the
gift to maximise your plausible
deniability a horrible gift much like
your pet always looks better when
dressed up and if you're going to to
re-gift have the decency to rewrap it
looks more festive and it spares you
from walking into a party in announcing
hey I brought you an appliance I didn't
want where's the eggnog if you're not
going to rewrap at the very least though
use a gift bag and I'll tell you why
gift bags are the sweatpants of gift
wrapping sure it's lazy but it's
undeniably better than not putting on
anything at all fine finally finally and
this one is very important keep yourself
to a single we gift per person do not I
repeat do not attempt to redistribute
all of your gifts amongst your friends
and family like a festive Ponzi scheme
you're flying too close to the Sun and
when your wings melts they'll probably
smell like a cranberry bog because you
made them from the scented candles you
got from your sister-in-law I do hope
this has been useful thank you so much
for watching we will be back in February
happy holidays and may all your problems
become someone else's goodbye
[Applause]